PRESENTER. THE DRIVE. ALL THE
TALKING MONEY. THE SECOND ON
BUSINESS PROFESSION AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WILL COME
TO ORDER. OR EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. ENPHASE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO. HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN ONE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER. TO THE SENATE OR OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY OE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IT. AND YOU WILL THEN
BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE. DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEES WILL
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE
WILL ONLY BE PERMITTED A TOTAL
OF THREE MINUTES. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
BE MAINTAINING DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY IN
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND TO CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER. AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME FOR
PARTICIPANTS. PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS. OR TECHNOLOGIES
SO PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES MAY BE HEARD. WE HAVE
NINE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA AT
THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST ONE
MEASURE HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA THAT IS ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN. AB EIGHT FOUR
FOUR. THERE ARE FOUR MEASURES
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT ITEM
NUMBER ONE A. B. TWO FOUR SIX.
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO NINE
EIGHT. ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B.
FOUR NINE SIX AND ITEM NUMBER
NINE A. B. THIRTEEN ZERO FIVE.
BEFORE YOUR PRESENTATION ON THE
BILLS LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ROTH ROTH
HERE MELINDA. ARCHULETA
ARTILLERY HERE BEATS BACKER
DADA EXAMINE HER TADO JONES.
JONES HERE LLEVA LABOR HERE MAN.
MAIN HERE NEW MAN NEWMAN HERE
AND SHOW ABODE AND SHOW ABOUT
HERE PAN. HERE IN HERE. WE HAVE
A QUORUM. WHY DON'T WE GO AHEAD
AND- TAKE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SIR MOTION. PLEASE CALL IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY US SAID ARCHULETA.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR FILE ITEMS ONE EIGHTY
TWO FORTY SIX VOLUMES TO A. B.
TWO NINE EIGHT. FILE ITEM FIVE
EIGHTY FOUR NINE SIX FILE ITEM
NINE A. B. ONE THREE ZERO FIVE
RALPH. BY RALPH HI MELINDA.
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BEAT
BECKER. BACKER HI MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO ASK YOU I REMIND YOU TO
PLEASE SPEAK INTO YOUR
MICROPHONE DAUGHTER. A MAN. HEY
MAN I HEARD TADO. JONES HI
JONES I. LEIVA. LEAVE THE
ICEMEN. MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN I
A SHOW ABOUT OKAY. A SHOW ABOUT
EYED. HERE I. THE CONCERT
CALENDAR HAS TEN VOTES WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. WELL I DON'T SEE
CIMBER MEMBERS AND IS. THERE IN
A SERVER COOLING. ARE YOU READY
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL WHICH IS.
AB FOUR SEVEN TWO YES INDEED-
CHAIRMAN GOOD MORNING ALL. OF
I'M HERE TO REPRESENT EIGHTY
FOUR SEVENTY TWO WHICH EXTENDS
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR EVENT
TICKET PURCHASES NOW AND LAW TO
INCLUDE CAMPSITE RESERVATIONS
OR BACKCOUNTRY PERMITS THAT
SORT OF THING FOR STATE AND
LOCAL CAMPGROUNDS TO THE
INCREASED DEMAND FOR OUTDOOR
ACTIVITIES AND CAMPING THE
PHENOMENON KNOWN AS BOT
SERVICES ROBOTS BUT BEGAN
PROMISING INDIVIDUALS THAT THEY
POSSESSED A SPECIAL BILL
RESERVE PREFERRED CAMPSITES. OF
BOTS RON LINE SUFFERED REFORM
AUTOMATED AND DIRECTED TASKS AT
SPEEDS FASTER THAN THE HUMAN
AND UNFAIRLY THEREFORE LIMIT
THE SUPPLY OF SITES FOR ENGINE
CAMPERS WHO HOPE TO GET
OUTDOORS BUT DON'T MAKE USE OF
THE SERVICES- IT IS TO BE
POINTED OUT THAT IN CALIFORNIA-
THE LAST. FULL YEAR IN WHICH
THIS. WOULD YOU MOVE THEM A WE
GO SIR THANKS THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH. ALL IN LAST FULL YEAR
WHICH THIS TYPE OF WORK IS
GOING ON WHICH TWENTY. BECAUSE
THE CAT AND MOUSE THE STATE
PARK SYSTEM. TO A TECHNICAL.
TECHNICAL INTERVENTION THERE
WERE SIX HUNDRED AND OF THIS
TYPE OF ACTIVITY IN THE
RESERVING SYSTEM- SO THIS BILL
IS JUST TRYING TO GO INTO THIS
AREA AND BACK UP. THE SYSTEM TO
ENSURE EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
CAMPGROUNDS AVOIDED NEW
SUPPLIES MAKING IT ILLEGAL
BECAUSE WE'VE ALREADY SEEN A
PROPENSITY FOR THIS GOING ON AS
WE SAY IT'S TWENTY EIGHTEEN-
WHAT WE'RE DOING SPECIFICALLY
HERE WE'RE ADDING CAMPSITE
RESERVATIONS AND WILDERNESS
PERMITS FOR THE EXISTING THOSE
PROVISIONS. WHICH PROHIBIT THE
USE OF THIS TYPE OF SOFTWARE
FOR. EVENTS OF VARIOUS TYPES-
AND- IT IS SIX PREVENT THE USE
OF THESE TO. CIRCUMVENT A
SYSTEM OF SECURITY THAT IS
MEANT TO ENSURE EQUAL ACCESS-
AND IT WILL GET IN FRONT OF THE
TECHNOLOGY CURVE IT A- SAFETY
RULE IN PLACE IN CALIFORNIA
AGAIN RESPONDED TO THE RECENT
PAST. OUR I'VE- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WILL NOW MOVE TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
BILL. WE'LL HEAR FROM WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY. I SEE NO
WITNESSES MOVING TO TESTIFY IN
THE GALLERY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE A
WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVEN TWO. I
SEE NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S
MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT ANY SUCH
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SEVEN TWO. WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY FOUR
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE O. LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A BEAT
FOUR SEVENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS.
ONE BUTTON ZERO NOW. IN AT THE
MOMENT IS THAT WE HAVE TWO
PEOPLE IN. ONE MON. LINE NUMBER
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
NATALIE NOT COMING UP WITH
CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT. MY NUMBER FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AND
CONCERNED COMMUNITY MEMBERS
SHOPPING PLAY ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY THING DIEGO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY OTHERS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. AND AT THE TIME OF
DAY CARE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTES
WE WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS AND HEAR FROM ANY
OPPOSITION LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN THE GALLERY
AND OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SEVEN TWO. SEEING NONE.
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD THINK
YOU WANT TO SHARE. THANK YOU
OKAY LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK IN THE QUEUE. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK AT THE
PORT OF A. B. OPPOSITION AT
EIGHTY FOUR SEVENTY TWO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THERE- NOW. AND
AT THE TIME OF THE DAY WE HAVE
NO ONE TO ONE UP. THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR LET'S BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO. THE CHAMBERS
FOR DISCUSSION AND COMMENT BY
MEMBERS CENTER ADMIN. H. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD JUST- THING MYSTICALLY
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
NOBODY NOBODY LIKES TO TRY TO
GET A SCAM SPOT AND NOT BE ABLE
TO GET IT AND THEN ONLY TO
REALIZE THAT IT IS INDEED WAS
THERE SO I WOULD. MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR SENATOR
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MR CHAIR BACK
QUICK QUESTIONS BECAUSE I THINK
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
LEGISLATION- I AGREE WITH
SENATOR EDMUND IT'S IMPORTANT
BUT I QUESTION ON THE
ENFORCEMENT IS OVER I
UNDERSTAND PROBABLY THIS
CREATES A DETERRENT BUT WHAT
WHAT HOW DO YOU ENFORCE THE
ORDER OR OTHERWISE INTERVENE
WHERE PEOPLE USING TECHNOLOGY
SECURITY. OPERATIONS LIKE THIS.
I THINK THE RECORD IS A HAVE A
ABLE TO WORK WITH THIS IS GOING
ON. AS IN TWENTY WHEN THEY'RE
SIX INSTANCES THEY DO KNOW THE
SYSTEMS ARE COMING IN IT GIVES
THEM AN ABILITY TO GO TO THE
SYSTEM OPERATORS. I DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE'S A THERE'S NO
LAWSUIT REMEDY HERE. BUT I
THINK IT IS SUCH A BRIGHT LINE
RULE THAT IT IS ILLEGAL UNLESS
THE STATE OUR REACH OUT
AGGRESSIVELY WITH SOME OF THESE
OPERATORS. THEY ARE ONLINE THE
EXTENT OF THEIR ONLINE THEY'RE
PROMOTING THEIR BUSINESS FOR
THE ACCESS SO THERE IS A WAY TO
TRACK THEM DOWN. AND PRECIADO
IT WHAT WHAT'S THE REMEDIES IT
MAY MEAN UNDER. WAY THEM IN
KIND OF A LOW. PROVISIONS ANTI
BOTCHED BUT WHAT ARE THEY ARE
THE- PENALTY. ARE THEY SHOULD
LOOK FOR. IN GOING TO. I THINK
WOULD BE FORCED WAR THE- POWER
GRAB GENERALLY. ON THAT ONE A
SENATOR NEWMAN. THIS KIND OF
PROVISIONS ALREADY PART OF THE
LAW. I THINK THAT THERE'S THE
SYSTEMS THEMSELVES LEAVE AN I.
D. THANK I'M NOT ACTUALLY IN
VENICE ENFORCER MECHANISM I'M
JUST EXTENDING THE LINE TO
CAMPGROUND RESERVATIONS SO I DO
THINK THERE ARE TECHNOLOGICAL
WAYS YOU'RE ABLE TO TRACK AND
IDENTIFY WHO'S COMING IN- I CAN
DO A LITTLE RESEARCH ON A ROUTE.
ALL UP TO YOU I I'D APPRECIATE
I'LL DO THE SAME THING ON THIS
TRIP. THANK YOU SEARCH. YES I'D
LIKE TO- PROGRESS THE AUTHOR
ACTUALLY BECAUSE I THINK IT'S A
GOOD ABOUT TIME WITH SO MANY
PEOPLE NOW- AFTER THE COVERT IS
ENDING HERE WE HAVE LOOKING AT
JUNE FIFTEENTH AROUND THE
CORNER- FAMILIES WANT TO GET
OUT THERE AND TO FIND THAT-
THERE WAS AN ISSUE THERE
BECAUSE OF THE SOFTWARE OR
INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL COMBAT
PLAYERS THAT. JUST WON'T GO
PLAY BY THE RULES IN THIS
ELIMINATE THE BAD ACTORS SO I
AM REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
BILL- AND SO I WOULD BE EXCITED
TO BE A CO AUTHOR SO
CONGRATULATIONS AND- I URGE YOU
TO VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR SIR
JONES. THANK YOU MR CHAIR. MOST
OF MY COMMENTS ARE AT ALL A
GREAT DEAL FOR YOU I'VE- THE
OLD SYSTEM I'VE USED THE NEW
SYSTEM. I USE THE- THE NATIONAL
PARK SYSTEM AND THE COUNTY PARK
SYSTEM SO- AND ACTUALLY THE NEW
STATE PARK SYSTEMS ACTUALLY
REALLY GOOD- SO I THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US FORWARD AND ALSO
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
IF I'M NOT ALREADY ON. AND
VERSION I WOULD ALSO THINK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. CONCERNS QUESTIONS
COLLEAGUES. SITTING NONE
MYSTICALLY WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
YES INDEED I WANT TO THANK THE
SUPPORTERS WHICH ALSO INCLUDES
THE EL DORADO IRRIGATION
DISTRICT. JUST TO UP. THE ROAD
OFF HIGHWAY FIFTY OUTSIDE MY
DISTRICT- AND IT IS THE CASE
YEAH YOU HEAR PEOPLE WHO
DESCRIBE. THEY'VE GONE CAMPING
IN AND THEY- THEY WON BIG GOT A
CAMPSITE FOR ONE NIGHT BECAUSE
SITES WHEN AVAILABLE. TO GET
THERE ONE NIGHT AND THEN
THERE'S SITES THROUGHOUT THE
CAMPGROUND THAT REMAIN VACANT
TO A WHOLE WEEKEND. SO REALLY
IS SOMETHING THAT JUST TAKES A
QUARTER OF PEOPLE IN THE NEXT
THIRTY- AND- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. AND REQUEST AND
I WILL. THANK YOU SIR BILL HAS
BEEN. BY CENTER EGGMAN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS FOR THE
COMMITTEE ON. PLAY CALL THE-
FILE ITEM FOR A B. FOR SEVENTY
DO PASS IN REAR FOR TO THE CAN
ON A PER. ROTH HI ROSS I'M ONLY.
ARCHULETA VIRTUAL I BE. BECKER
HI BECKER I'D DAUGHTER. EGGMAN
HI A MAN I HEARD I FOR TOM I
JOAN HI JOHN I. LEAVE A MEAN HI
MIN I KNEW HI NEWMAN I CHOSE
ABODE I A SHOW A GUY CAN HI HE
N. I. BILL HAS ELEVEN VOTES
ENOUGH TO GET OUT WILL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN FOR EPSON MA'AM THANK
YOU GO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEVEN MEMBER AND IS THERE AN
ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B. FOUR
SIX FIVE. THANK YOU MR CHAIR
AND COLLEAGUES GOOD MORNING-
TODAY I'LL BE PRESENTING D.
BEFORE SIXTY FIVE THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARIES RECEIVE CULTURAL
COMPETENCY TRAINING FOR SERVING
PATIENTS IN THE L. G. B. T. Q.
I. PLUS RELIGIOUS AND ETHNIC
COMMUNITIES. PROFESSIONAL
FIDUCIARIES PROVIDE CRITICAL
SERVICES TO SENIORS AND PERSONS
WITH DISABILITIES THEY MANAGE
MATTERS FOR CLIENTS INCLUDING
DAILY CARE HOUSING AND MEDICAL
NEEDS UNFORTUNATELY THE L. G.
B. T. Q. WHY SENIORS FACE
UNIQUE CHALLENGES AS THEY AGE
AND ARE AMONG THE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION. IN OUR
SOCIETY THESE CHALLENGES
INCLUDE BARRIERS TO RECEIVING
FORMAL HEALTH CARE AND SOCIAL
SUPPORT THAT HETEROSEXUAL AND
CISGENDER ADULTS DO NOT
ENCOUNTER SEVERAL STUDIES
REPORT OF G. B. T. Q. I. PLUS
SENIORS AVOID OR DELAY HEALTH
CARE OR CONCEAL THEIR SEXUAL
AND GENDER IDENTITY FROM HEALTH
PROVIDERS AND SOCIAL SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS. FOR FEAR OF
DISCRIMINATION IN ADDITION
COMPARED TO HETEROSEXUAL
CISGENDER ADULTS L. G. B. T. Q.
I. PLUS OLDER ADULTS TYPICALLY
HAVE FEWER OPTIONS FOR INFORMAL
CARE AND ARE LESS LIKELY TO
HAVE FAMILY TO TURN TO FOR
CARE. EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE IS
INTENDED TO ENSURE THAT L. G.
B. T Q. Y. PLUS RELIGIOUS AND
ETHNIC SENIORS GET COMPETENT
AND RESPECTFUL CARE BY
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES BY
REQUIRING CULTURAL COMPETENCY
AND SENSITIVITY TRAINING DURING
THE EDUCATION AND LICENSING
PROCESS. WITH ME- I'M JOINED BY
TAMMY MARTIN WITH A QUALITY
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS JERRY
DESMOND ON BEHALF OF THE
PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED. MISS
MARTIN. MR DOES GOOD MORNING
MANY. YES THIS IS TAMMY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WE'RE
HAPPY TO HERE TO AS THE SPONSOR
OF THE EIGHTY FIVE WHICH ARE
THE YOUNGER PLANES WERE
EQUIPPED NEW AND PROFESSIONAL.
WITH THE TOOL THEY NEED TO AND
ACTED CLIENTS WHO ARE LESBIAN
GAY TRANS OR ENTER. I NEED TO
WILL HELP YOU IN THAT
PROFESSION PRODUCE CAN FULFILL
DUTIES ACTIVE WAYS THAT ARE ON.
AND THE BACK INSURANCE OF THEIR-
MANY OF WHOM ARE IN A
VULNERABLE TO BEGIN WITH AND
LGBTQ I FIND PEOPLE ARE NO
EXCEPTION- MANY HAVE
EXPERIENCEDDISCRIMINATION IN
HEALTH CARE SPENDING LEADING
THEM SHOOT DIDN'T DELAY
NECESSARY CARE OR AVOID IT
ALTOGETHER FOR EXAMPLE AND MANY
HAVE BEEN REJECTED BY FAMILY OR
BEEN UNABLE TO BUILD A FAMILY
AND THEREFORE HAVE FEWER
OPTIONS FOR INFORMAL CARE THE
PROFESSIONAL PRETTY SURE EITHER
CRITICAL REPORTS OUR COMMUNITY.
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR THAT
IMPORTANT BILL AND YOUR SEX
YOUR CLASSIC SUPPORT TODAY WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
NEXT. PLEASE JEREMY THE DOES ON
BEHALF OF THE- FIDUCIARY ASSOC
THE CAL. IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WE APPRECIATE THE TO WORK WITH
THE R. AND SPA. TO ENSURE THAT
THE- OF CULTURAL. WILL BE ONE
OF THE WORKERS PROFESSION. WE
AGREE WITH THE HOUR OF THE DAY.
C. D. AND THEN ONE HOUR THREE
YEARS OF. C. E. WITH THE COURSE
OF THE OF COURSE PROVIDERS ARE
PRE BY PROFESSIONAL- SHERRY'S.
AND IT'LL ALSO OVERSEE THE THAT
PROVIDED ON A NON BASIS. THANK
YOU AND WE'RE JUST. THANK YOU
BOTH FOR YOUR COMMENTS WILL NOT%
FROM ANY WITH. HERE THE GALLERY.
C. NONE ARE THERE ANY WITH AND
RE ONE TWO WHICH TEST OF IN
SOME. OF A FORCE FIVE. SITTING
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OVER THIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR SIX FIVE WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU AT THE CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE IN THEIR OWN NOW. AND
AT THIS TIME OF THE CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE TO. THANK YOU LET'S
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCEDURE AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR SIX FIVE. SEEING NONE.
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OF US IN
OPPOSITION AMANDA MODERATOR IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH WITNESSES WANTING TO
TESTIFY WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB FORTY FIVE.
PRESS ONE THEN THERE- NOW. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH A LINE NUMBER IN PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. THAT'S ONE.
ZERO AND AT THE TIME OF DAY
CARE WE HAVE NO ONE TO YOU.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS
IN THE CHAMBER COLLEAGUES. ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS OR CONCERNS
DR PAM. THANK YOU MR CHAIR AND-
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING- THIS
ISSUE FORWARD- WELL I GUESS-
FIRST OF ALL COMMENTS AND THEN
MAYBE PERHAPS QUESTION- THE-
BIGGEST MOST BECOMING I WOULD
MAKE IS THAT- I THINK THE
PURPOSES AND GOALS OF THIS-
PARTICULAR BILL CERTAIN VERY
IMPORTANT SO IT'S IMPORTANT
THA PROFESSIONAL FIDUCIARIES-
RECEIVED- OUR OUR KNOWLEDGE.
ABOUT- CALL- WELL I LIKE THE
WORD CO SECTOR BETTER TO COMP
IN CULTURE COMPETENCE REALLY ME
BUT- BUT ESSENTIALLY- COUPLE
AND AS IN. THE IMPORT THAT THEY
HAVE THAT KNOWLEDGE BASE A I
THINK I'VE EXPRESSED IN THIS
COMMITTEE ON NUMEROUS OCCASIONS
CONCERNS ABOUT. MANDATORY CM-
CONTINUING EDUCATION BECAUSE
FROM ADULT LEARNING
PERSPECTIVE- IT'S- IT'S BETTER
TO HAVE PEOPLE IDENTIFY AREAS
WHERE THEY HAVE GAPS AND THEN
HAVE THEM PURSUE. THAT
EDUCATION THEY'RE MORE LIKELY
CHANGE BEHAVIOR FROM THAT AND
THROUGH MANTA THAT REQUIRED
COURSES- TELLING THEY HAVE TO
TAKE SOMETHING YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE IN WHICH CASE THEY SIMPLY
CHECK THE BOX AND DOESN'T
ACTUALLY CHANGE YOUR BEHAVIOR.
SO SO IT'S SOMETHING TAT I DO
HAVE THAT CONCERN WHEN IT EVER
COMES TO A- BILL THAT. WE'RE WE
REQUIRE A PARTICULAR TYPE OF
EDUCATION- THROUGH CONTINUING
EDUCATION HOWEVER I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT IN THIS PARTICULAR
BILL THIS IS SUPPORTED BY THE
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENTS
THE FIDUCIARY SPECIAL FIDUCIARY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA SO I DO
APPRECIATE THAT AT LEAST WITHIN
THE ORGAN THE PROFESSION
ITSELF. THAT THERE'S A DESIRE
FOR THIS KIND OF REQUIREMENT- I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS THAT IN
TERMS OF THE- AND I DID HEAR
TESTIMONY FROM THE PROFESSION.
FIDUCIA CESSATION. THE V. SO-
WHO IS- WHO'S GOING TO TURN
WHICH ACTUALLY THIS. AND THEN
ADD AND THE CON AND IS THERE
ANY HOPE- TO SHOW ASIDE FROM
SOMEONE TAKE THE COURSE TO MEET
THE PRESS DIRECT IS THAT SOME.
OF THE NOW OR THEIR- THEIR
ACTUAL APPLICATION OF WHAT'S
BEING TIED SO ANOTHER WORDS ARE
WE DOING ANY SERVICE SUSSMAN OF
THE ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE OR ACTUAL
BEHAVIOR OF THE FINISH OF THIS
PRODUCE YOUR EIGHT IN TERMS OF
THAT REFLECTS A CULTURAL.
EFFECTIVENESS OR CULTURAL
COMPETENCE. BUSINESS ARE THANK
YOU. FOR SOME OF YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND FOR YOUR
QUESTION AS WELL DR AND AS AS
YOU KNOW I. I'VE NOT REALLY
DABBLED MUCH IN THIS SPACE-
BECAUSE I TOO BELIEVE THAT IF
YOU ARE CONFIDENT IF YOU ARE
FOLLOWING UP. IN YOUR CAREER
AND YOU ARE KEEPING UP TO DATE.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS THAT YOU
PROBABLY DON'T NEED- IN FACT
MANY OCCASIONS WE- ARE GO
THROUGH ETHICS TRAINING AND
THERE'S A FINE THERE'S A- VERY
DISTINCT LINE BETWEEN ETHICS
AND HOW MUCH TRAINING YOU CAN
GET AND- THE MORALS THAT YOU
PLAN ON A DAILY BASIS. SO I I'M
WITH OU ON THAT- IT'S JUST
THAT THIS WAS SUCH A SENSITIVE
ISSUE AND GIVEN WHERE THINGS
ARE AT GIVEN WHERE HOW SOME
COMMUNITIES ARE NOT TREATED-
THE WAY WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THEM TREATED. IT WAS IMPORTANT
FOR US TO. PLACE A STANDARD- TO
YOUR QUESTION SPECIFICALLY I
BELIEVE THE P. FAQ WHICH IS THE
PROFESSIONAL PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION. WILL BE PROVIDING
THE GUIDELINES AND BE
THEMSELVES ALSO ARE AN APPROVED
PROVIDER OF THESE- ONGOING
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU APPRECIATE-
APPRECIATE THAT- I THINK AGAIN-
BECAUSE THE PROFESSIONAL
PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION IS ALSO
YOU KNOW SOUNDS LIKE IT IS NOW
IN SUPPORT OF THE ONE SPONSORS
BUT CERTAINLY SEEMS LIKE A VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER TESTIFIED HERE
THAT DOES MAKE ME A- LITTLE
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH SAYING.
THIS REQUIREMENTS OKAY BUT I
JUST WANNA BE SURE THAT YOU
KNOW GENERALLY NOT TOO KEEN
ABOUT THOSE THINGS AT THE END
IN MY MIND IF THERE IS ANY
OTHER ALSO MEASURES WAYS TO
ASSESS AS TO- IN ADDITION TO IS
JUST SOMEONE HAVING TAKEN A
CLASS THAT THERE'S SOME WAY YOU
KNOW EXPECTATION WE CAN HAVE
PEOPLE DEMONSTRATE THEIR
ACTUAL. APPLICATION OR
CANCIONES COMPETENT OF FORKS-
MUSICAL COMPETENCE THE OUTCOMES
WOULD ALSO IN MY MIND ACTUALLY
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT THAN TAKING
A COURSE IN ITSELF SO I WOULD I
WOULD ENCOURAGE IT. YOUR I
GUESS THE ASSOCIATION AND THE
BOARD TO LOOK AT WAYS PEOPLE
CAN ACTUALLY DEMONSTRATE THE
ACTUAL APPLICATION OF THE TYPES
OF TOPICS THAT WOULD BE COVERED
IN THE- REQUIREMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN YOUR BILL SELF
THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK YOU-
CENTER PENSER JONES. CHAIRMAN
AND FASTENERS CENTER PANIC
SHARE A SIMILAR PHILOSOPHY ON
CONTINUING EDUCATION I
TYPICALLY HAVE A HARD TIME OF
SUPPORTING LEGISLATIVE MANDATES
A CONTINUING EDUCATION I
UNDERSTAND THE ASSOCIATIONS. IN
FAVOR- WHAT WHERE'S THE BORDER
THIS AND- SO I GUESS QUESTIONS
WERE THE BOARD ON IT AND THEY
ARE. ON IT AND NUMBER TWO CAN'T
JUST MAKE THE CHANGE THEM SO.
WHY IS IT RE. RELIGIOUS
OVERSIGHT TO DO. THAT'S A
QUESTION BECAUSE I BROUGHT THIS
BILL FIRST FIRST TIME AROUND
TWO YEARS AGO PRIOR TO KOBE- SO
I PROBABLY ASKED THAT QUESTION
EARLY ON AND I CAN'T REMEMBER
IT BECAUSE I HAVEN'T REVISITED
IT SO I'M HAPPY TO GET BACK TO
YOU SENATOR- BUT I BECAUSE
THAT'S ONE OF THE FIRST
QUESTIONS THEY DO ASK AS WELL
WHY DO WE NEED A BILL- BUT- IT.
I ATE. LET ME GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT. BUT I DO ALSO SHARE
YOUR SENTIMENT ALONG WITH
DOCTOR PENNED ABOUT LIMITING
RIGHT. THE ONGOING BASIS OF
THIS- I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR JOHN STINNER ARCHULETA
YES- THANK YOU AND MY QUESTION
THE AUTHOR IS- YEAH I NOTICED
THAT FOR THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
YOU WERE JUST TRYING TO PRESENT
SOMETHING ACROSS LIKE THIS AND
IT WAS EVEN VETOED BY- GOVERNOR
BROWN WAY BACK IN. BUT THEY'RE
SUCH A STRONG NEED ANYTHING FOR
EQUALITY AND FAIRNESS AND
UNDERSTANDING OF OTHER CULTURES
AND SEAN WERE FINDING THAT O
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW WHETHER IT
BE THE LESBIAN COMMUNITY GAY
BISEXUAL TRANSGENDER DOESN'T
MATTER IS WE NEED TO KNOW.
ABOUT ONE ANOTHER AND HOW WE
CAN INTERACT TO BE BETTER
CITIZENS AND COME TOGETHER AND
WORK TOGETHER AND IF THIS BILL
WILL OPEN THAT DOOR AND- INSURE
THAT EVERYONE IN THIS
PROFESSION HAVE THE SENSITIVITY
AND KNOWLEDGE HOW TO DEAL WITH
ONE ANOTHER. BECAUSE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT COUNSELING-
INDIVIDUALS FINANCIALLY IN DAY
CARE AND HOUSING AND MEDICAL
pEVERYONE SHOULD HAVE GOT TO
KNOW THAT WE'VE GOT TO BE FAIR
AND EQUITABLE ACROSS THE BOARD
EVERYONE. SHOW I AM I WAS
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AND I
THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME AND- BUT
MY QUESTION- TO THIS FAMILY
MEMBER IS WHY DO YOU THINK YOU
HAD PROBLEMS IN THE PAST. AND
SO DID YOU PUT AMENDMENTS
TOGETHER HOW DID YOU GET SO FAR
AND I THINK. I WOULD HOPE THAT
NOW WHERE YOU'RE AT A POINT OF
ACTUALLY PASSING THIS BILL BUT
WHAT. WERE SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
YOU HAD AND WHY DO YOU THINK
YOU HAD A- THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION OF. SO HE- I- THE TWO
KIND OF A OUT THE NICEST WAY OF
SAYING THIS- I BELIEVE THAT
THIS THERE WAS A
MISUNDERSTANDING AND A MISTAKE
AND THAT'S WHY THE VETO WAS-
BROUGHT ABOUT THE FIRST TIME
AROUND- THAT'S THAT'S THE- I
JUST WISH I CAN EXPLAIN
DESCRIBE THE SCENARIO BECAUSE-
THIS WAS NOT THE ONLY BUILDER
WAS A SECOND BILL ALSO THAT
BASED ON A MISUNDERSTANDING WAS
WE TOOK- SO. BUT BUT BUT I'VE
WORKED WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
THERE'S NO ISSUES OR CONCERNS
AND SO THIS IS GOING TO BE
MOVING FORWARD AT THIS POINT.
UP AT ONCE IT PASSES HOPEFULLY
HERE AND THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE FLOOR- I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION IS IN A PLACE
WHERE THEY'RE FAVORABLE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR.
HOLLINGS FURTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. SAYING
NONE- ANGELA TO CLOSE- BY JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A RIVAL
AND I APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS THAT WERE PROVIDED
THANK YOU THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIX FIVE. SEARCH A LOT OF MIXED
EMOTIONS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. VIOLATING THREE AB FOUR
SIX FIVE DO YOU PASS AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RALPH HI. RALPH
HI MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA ALL
RIGHT ARCHULETA I'D BEAT.
BECKER HI. BECKER I DIED ALL.
THOUGHT I A MAN I ADNAN I HER
TADO I- TATO I. JONES. JONES NO
LLEVA. MAN NEW MAN HI NEWMAN I
CHOSE OKAY HI A SHOW ABOUT A
GUY PIANO. VOTE DATA ONE NO
SOLUTION GET UP BOOK THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN IF YOU DON'T
MIND ME JUST COMMENT MAKING ONE
COMMENT SINCE THE BILL IS OUT
AT THIS POINT I JUST WANT TO
SAY SINCE THIS IS MY FIRST.
BILL ON THE SENATE SIDE
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE OF US
RETURNING- THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME APPEARING IN FRONT OF THE
SENATE IN TWO YEARS SO IT'S
WONDERFUL TO BE BACK TO BE WITH
ALL OF YOU I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND TO SOME OF
THE NEWER NEWER AND RETURNING
AND FORMER COLLEAGUES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY IT'S WONDERFUL TO SEE
YOU ALL THANK YOU. FOR THANK
YOU SIR. NEXT ITEM NUMBER. SIX
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIX NINE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON. WHEN
YOU'RE READY SIR. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT A B. FIVE SIX NINE
SPONSORED BY THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD WHICH
RAISES THE MAXIMUM CAP ON CIVIL
PENALTY FEES FOR CONTRACTORS
ONLY 3% OF CONTRACTORS ARE
SUBJECT TO A CIVIL PENALTY FEE
EACH YEAR. BUT FOR THE FEW BAD
ACTORS THAT DO EXIST CIVIL
PENALTY FEES ARE AN IMPORTANT
TOOL TO DETER VIOLATING THE LAW
UNFORTUNATELY THESE FREE CAPS
ARE DECADES OUT OF DATE FOR
MOST VIOLATIONS OF CONTRACTORS
LAW THE MAXIMUM FEE THAT THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
CAN CHARGE. A CONTRACTOR WAS
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS
AMOUNT WAS ESTABLISHED IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE OVER SEVENTEEN
YEARS. OR A GREGIS CONTRACTORS
CAN BE CHARGED UP TO FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS VIOLATION
SPECIFIC MAXIMUM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO IT IS NEVER BEEN INCREASED
IN TWENTY NINE YEARS.
ADDITIONALLY WHEN A CONTRACTOR
APPEALS A CITATION IT NOW COSTS
THE C. S. O. B. AT LEAST TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO DEFEND IN
COURT PLUS THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN EXPENSES FROM THE OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS. EIGHTY
FIVE SIXTY NINE SOLVES THESE
PROBLEMS BY RAISING THE CAPS ON
CIVIL PENALTY FEES TO BRING
THEM IN LINE WITH THE CURRENT
CONSUMER PRICE PRICE INDEX ALSO
THIS MEASURE ALLOWS THE CSO B.
TO ISSUE AN ADMONISHMENT LETTER
WHEN EDUCATION OR PROOF OF
COMPLIANCE IS DETERMINED TO BE
A BETTER APPROACH THAN A
CITATION. EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY
NINE WILL HELP OFFSET THE COST
FACED BY THE CSO B. IN
DEFENDING CITATIONS AGAINST BAD
ACTORS AND ENSURE THAT CIVIL
PENALTY FEES REMAIN A VABLE
DETERRENT TO VIOLATING THE LAW.
THE COMMON SENSE APPROACH WILL
ALLOW THE CSO B. TO CONTINUE
EFFECTIVELY REGULATING THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA I DO HAVE WITH ME-
WAR- TO TESTIFY MIKE JIM THAT
SKIED WITH THE CSL BE. PLEASE
PROCEED SIR. HELLO MR JIM
THAT'S KING. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR MEMBERS MIGHT GENETICALLY
FREDDIE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD PLEASED TO
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE I SEE A
FAMILY MEMBER STATED THERE ARE
TWO MAIN BENEFITS FOR THIS BILL
REALLY JUST TO BRING
ADMINISTRATIVE FINES TO MODERN
DAY LEVELS AND ALLOW MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO ISSUE
ADMONISHMENT LETTERS IN LIEU OF
THOSE FINES- WITH THAT I'M
CERTAINLY AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS BUT I DO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU SIR SIR WE
WERE NOW HEAR FROM ANYONE. IN
THE GET. I DON'T SEE ANY
FURTHER ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SIX NINE. SEEING NONE THANK YOU
WE WILL MOVE TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE SIX NINE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B. FIVE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A. B. FIVE SIXTY
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE. IN THEIR
OWN NOW. IT IS TIME WE HAVE ONE
PERSON WITH THE CHAIR. A LINE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I LIKE
TWENTY ONE YOU DON'T SEEM TO BE
GOING IN ORDER SO I'M A LITTLE
BIT CONFUSED BY THE AGENDA AND
WHEN I NEED TO BE CALLING IT
MAKES IT CHALLENGING FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO KNOW WHEN TO
CALL. WHEN YOU DON'T GO IN
ORDER WHEN YOU DON'T HONOR THE
AGENDA. TO WHAT BILL ARE YOU ON.
MA'AM WE ARE OWN ITEM NUMBER
SIX ASSEMBLY BILL YOUR ITEM
NUMBER SIX BUT WHAT HAPPENED TO
FOUR AND FIVE I'M WAITING FOR
THE CAMPSITE RESERVATION BILL
AND COOLLY WHAT HAPPENED TO
THAT. YOU WENT STRAIGHT FROM
THE INTO BUT THAT'S WHAT YOUR
AGENDA AS WELL MA'AM IF YOU HAD
IF YOU WERE ON THE LINE WHEN WE
STARTED THE HEARING. MR COOLEY
PRESENTED HIS BILL FIRST. HI
MICHELLE IT'S INTERESTING THAT
MR COOLEY DOES WHAT MR COOLEY
DOES AND HE DOESN'T HAVE TO
FOLLOW THE AGENDA I FIND THAT
QUITE FASCINATING. BECAUSE HE
LISTED. WELL MEMBER KERR ON
ASSEMBLY FIVE SIX NINE DO YOU
HAVE COMMENTS WITH RESPECT TO
THAT BILL. COMMENTS ABOUT MR
COOLEY AND HIM WALKING THE
BUILDING AND KEEPING PEOPLE OUT
AND I'M SAYING NO TO HIS
CAMPSITE BILL AND I FIND IT
FASCINATING THAT YOU'RE. THANK
YOU BUT THE CHAIR LINE NUMBER
TWENTY THREE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS SCOTT GOVERNOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF A. B.
FIVE SIX NINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SIR. NEXT. AT
THE TIME OF THE DAY WE HAVE NO
ONE I YOU WELL THAT'S FALLEN
OUT OF THE SAME PROCEDURE AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES BEGINNING WITH
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY I. SEE
NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S CHECK
ROOM ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF THEIR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION. TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FIVE FIVE SIX NINE I SEE NO
WITNESSES THERE. LET'S NOW MOVE
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS.
MODERATOR ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO ASSEMBLY. BILL
FIVE SIX NINE WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR WAITED ON.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK ABOUT. OF
EIGHTY FIVE SIXTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
THE ONLINE NUMBER AND PLACE YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAKING OPPOSITION A.
B. SIXTY NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THERE- NOW. AND AT THIS
TIME A TEACHER WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE YOU. THANK YOU LET'S BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS IN THE CHAMBER
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. REGARDING
THIS BILL. SEEINGNONE AS
GRAYSON WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
YES MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I KIND
OF WANTED TO BE A PART OF A
LIVELY DEBATE OVER ANOTHER
MEMBER'S BILL AND- RESPECTFULLY
ASK WHEN I'VE- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION THE SIM BILL. FIVE SIX
NINE. MR DOT MISTER DARDEN
MOVES THE BILL. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FAIL ITEMS SIX
AB FIVE SIX NINETY PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY ROTH FIVE ROSS I
MELINDA'S. ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA
I'D BE. BACKER ALL RIGHT BECKER
I DIED HI DONNA HI EIGHT MIN ON
HEY I HER TADO I'VE HER TADO
I'D JONES HI JONES I LEIVA. MAN
NEWMAN NINE NEW MEN HI AT SHOW
ABOUT OKAY. A SHOW ABOUT A GUY
HI HERE IN I. THE BILL IS TEN
VOTES SUFFICIENT TO GET OUT
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT IS FILE ITEM EIGHT
ASSEMBLY BILL. TEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN. PLEASE
PROCEED SIR WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU- MR TERRENCE SANDERS
ONLY TO START OFF BY COMMENTING
ON HOW RADIANT AND FULL OF
WISDOM ALL OF YOU LOOK THIS
MORNING- AND WHAT A PLEASURE IT
IS TO SEE EVERYBODY TODAY. I'D
LIKE TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT FOR HER
WORK ON THE BUILDING WITH US ON
THE TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS IN THE
ANALYSIS CLIMATE SCIENTISTS
AGREE THAT OUR SOCIETY MUST
PREPARE FOR A ZERO CARBON
FUTURE NOW SO WE NEED TO ENSURE
THAT DESIGN PROFESSIONALS ARE
PREPARED FOR OUR NEW CLIMATE
REALITY. THE CURRENT CONTINUING
EDUCATION IS LIMITED TO
DISABILITY ACCESS WHICH MEANS
THAT MANY ARCHITECTS MAY HAVE
LITTLE OR NO EXPOSURE TO
STRATEGIES FOR REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS IN
CONSTRUCTION THEREFORE EIGHTY
TEN TEN IT WOULD REQUIRE THAT
ARCHITECTS LICENSED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO COMPLETE
FIVE HOURS OF ZERO NET CARBON
CONTINUING EDUCATION. FOR TWO
YEAR RENEWAL CYCLE THE
COMMITTEE RAISED A QUESTION
ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY OF
APPROPRIATE TRAINING WELL MY
WITNESSES CAN PROVIDE MORE
DETAIL I WOULD KNOW THAT THERE
ARE SEVERAL PROVIDERS ALREADY
IN THE SPACE MOREOVER WITH THE
GROWING ACKNOWLDGEMENT OF THE
NEED TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
IN DESIGN I WOULD EXPECT MORE
PROVIDERS AND CLASSES WILL SOON
BE AVAILABLE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I WROTE. THANK YOU
SIR I BELIEVE MIKE BELOW ON
BEHALF OF K. A. CALIFORNIA AND
BILL LEDDY ARCHITECT MEMBER.
MAY BE ON THE LINE TO TESTIFY.
YES THANK YOU MR KERR I AM LIKE
THE LOAD FOR A I. A CALIFORNIA-
YOU KNOW NET ZERO CARBON REALLY
IS THE DESIGN ISSUE OF OUR TIME
AND IT APPLIES TO ALL TYPES OF
PROPERTIES WITHIN THE BUILT
ENVIRONMENT SO RESIDENTIAL
COMMERCIAL. INDUSTRIAL PRIVATE
PROPERTIES PUBLIC PROPERTIES
SUCH AS HOSPITALS AND SCHOOLS
AND- FACILITIES. THE TECHNOLOGY
REALLY IS CHANGING AT WARP
SPEED EVERY YEAR IS DIFFERENT
IN TERMS OF WHAT IS AVAILABLE.
TO REDUCE THE CARBON FOOTPRINT.
THE SECOND IS TAUGHT AND SO IT
IS A PART OF PRE LICENSING
EDUCATION. BUT YOU KNOW MANY
ARCHITECTS MIGHT BE YEARS OR
EVEN DECADES PAST. BY THE TIME
WHICH THEY- QUALIFIED FOR THEIR
LICENSE BY EDUCATION AN
EXAMPLE. OF THE WAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY LICENSED
ARCHITECT HAS SOME EXPOSURE TO
THIS CRITICAL. ISSUE IS
CONTINUING EDUCATION- THERE ARE
MANY PROVIDERS ALREADY AS MR
OPPERMAN INDICATED NOT JUST A
I. EIGHT. THERE IS A NEW
BUILDING INSTITUTE- COURSES BY
HANLEY WOOD GREEN BUILDING
EDUCATION SERVICES COMPANY AND
WE THINK THAT MANY MANY MORE
WILL BE COMING. AND THE
REQUIREMENT ON DISABILITY
ACCESS I THINK IT'S A LESS
PRODUCE IN THE TEN YEARS THAT
THAT REQUIREMENT HAS EXISTED.
THERE BEEN OVER SIX HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DIFFERENT COURSES BY A
TREMENDOUS VARIETY OF PROVIDERS.
A. I. A. IS A DISTINCT MINORITY
SO THE THERE IS NO MONOPOLY
GOING ON HERE WE THINK THE
COURSES ARE AVAILABLE NOW WE
THINK A LOT MORE WILL BE
COMING. YOU KNOW WE'RE VERY
MINDFUL OF THE COMMENTS OF DR
AND THEN SENATOR JONES- IN
TERMS OF. OUTPUT BUILDING CODES
ARE CHANGING REGULARLY IN THIS
AREA TO REFLECT- THE INCREDIBLE
NEED TO REDUCE CARBON
FOOTPRINT. SO ONE OF THE WAYS
TO MEASURE OUTPUT IS ON THE
ISSUANCE OF BUILDING PERMITS BY
LOCAL BUILDING OFFICIALS WHO
SUPPORT THE BILL. BUT WE DO
THINK THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE
THAT NEEDS TO GET GOING AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE THE BILL WILL ALLOW
THIS TO BE A REQUIREMENT FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY THREE RENEWAL
CYCLE. THAT'S THE EARLIEST IT
CAN BE INCORPORATED WERE
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT AND WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EYE POKE.
WITH ME AS YOU NOTED MR KERR'S
BILL LADY FROM. PRACTICING
ARCHITECT TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE HELP.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. WE
WILL HEAR FROM WITNESSES THE
GALLERY HAS NONE LOOK AT ROOM
ONE TWELVE TO SEE IF THERE
WITNESS THERE WERE TO TEST IN.
OF THIS BILL I SEE NO WITH
THERE. LET'S NUMBER ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELECONFERENCE ORBIS
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROMPT. ANY SUCH INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF ASSEMBLY BILL TEN TEN. WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. TEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN IF ZERO. AND THE OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER IN PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A. B. TEN
TEN. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW. IS THE JOB THAT
WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE IN Q. ONE
MOMENT FOR THE FIRST ONE. LIE
NUMBER TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWENTY ONE I'M CALLING IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOUR SEVEN TWO
BY CRUELTY AND YOU DIDN'T
FOLLOW THE AGENDA. SO I'M
STRUGGLING UNDER. CALIFORNIANS
ARE SUPPOSED. ONE MOMENT WITH
THE CHAIR FOR THE NEXT PERSON
THANK YOU. WE'RE GETTING A LINE
NUMBER NOW ONE MOMENT SIR. THE
LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING VERY HEARING ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT OF THE V.
TEN TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. HERE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU WILL
NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION
BEGINNING WITH WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY. AND SEE NO WITNESSES
IN THE GALLERY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO ASSEMBLY BILL. TEN TEN. SEE
NO SUCH WITNESSES LET'S MOVE
TO. WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULDPLEASE PROMPT ANY
SUCH WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION WE WILL
BEGIN GIVEN. THANK YOU AT THE
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WANT TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
A BABY TEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE ONLINE
NUMBER AND PLACE IT BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
TEN TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE- NOW. AND AT THIS TIME IF
YOU CAN'T WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO MEMBERS. IN THE CHAMBER
SENATOR NEWMAN. DAY RICHARD
LIKE TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR- ON
BRINGING THIS BILL AND I'D LIKE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF
SUCH. AND SUCH TIME TO PROVIDE
ALSO LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL-
WHEN THAT TIME IS APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU. PERFECT THANK YOU
SENATOR SENATOR JONES THANK YOU
MR CHAIR AT JUST THE SIMILAR
CONCERNS TO THE LAST BILL. ON
THE CONTINUING EDUCATION- YOU
KNOW. HERE IN MY- WITH ERICA.
WITH LEE SORT OF- AND ALL THE
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING
IS LIKE A NATURAL COMP
COMPETITIVE ISSUE WITH THE-
INDUSTRY. IN ARCHITECTURE EVERY
DAY TRYING TO GET BETTER AND
BETTER WHAT THEY DO. READING
FIVE HOURS OF. OF THIS TYPE OF
EDUCATION- YOU KNOW IT'S FIVE
HOURS ENOUGH. BUT THE YOU KNOW
THE OVERARCHING CONCERN FOR ME
IS IT LEGISLATIVELY. REQUIRED
FOR THE BOARD TO BUILD MAKE
THIS CHANGE RIGHT AT THE BOARD
JUST DO IT WITHOUT LATEST
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. BRIGITTE
THAT SENDER AND THEN WE'LL
DEFER TO- EITHER MY WITNESSES
IF THEY HAVE COMMENTS IN TERMS
OF CONVERSATIONS WITH THE BOARD
I KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
WITH THE BOARD ABOUT THE BILL-
AND THEN THE BOARD CHAIR
RECENTLY OR THE BOARD PRESIDENT
RECENTLY SIGNED OFF ON- THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE MAKING
TODAY- BUT THIS WAS SOMETHING
THAT WAS BROUGHT TO US BY. BY
THE ARCHITECTS BY A SO- YOU
KNOW THEY THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
AND WILL BE VALUABLE TO THEIR
MEMBERS AND THEN. TOOK AWHILE
BUT APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS
THAT YOU HAVE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER. THANK YOU I WANT
TO COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE FOR
BRINGING THIS LEGISLATION
FORWARD AND HEAR THE CONCERNS
OF MIGHT OF- THAT MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER JONES I DO WANT TO SAY I
DO THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT TOPIC IT WAS NOTED
THE COMMITTEE NOW SAYS 40% OF
CARBON EMISSIONS ARE FROM
BUILDINGS AND CONSISTENT WITH
MY DAD SB SIXTY EIGHT WE TALKED
ABOUT HOW CONTRACTORS THEY'RE
NOT OF CONTRACTORS WHO
UNDERSTAND. ON THE- YOU KNOW
THE KIND OF SCIENCE AND
AVAILABILITY OF A NEW ELECTION
YOU KNOW ALL LECTURE
COMPLIANCES LIKE HEAT PUMPS AND
OTHER THINGS AND I THINK IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL THAT THE
ARCHITECTS UNDERSTAND TO WHAT
IS NOW POSSIBLE BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MUCH NEW- ON NEW SITES EVERY
DAY NOW AND NEW MATURE IN A NEW
BUILDING MATERIALS AND SUCH SO
I COMMEND THIS. EFFORT AND I DO
THINK- WILL BE CENSORED
CONCERNS OF COME OVER
LEGISLATING. THESE BOARDS I
THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ONE.
EIGHT THESE ARE. THANK YOU
SENATOR DR. I YOU THANK YOU FOR
MUCH AND SHARE FIRST OF ALL I
DO WANT COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
A FOR TRYING TO DRESS- THIS
ISSUE OF BEING SURE THAT
ARCHITECTS- HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE
AND SKILLS. TO DO- YOU KNOW.
ZERO NET CARBON- DESIGN YEAH.
IN AND I THINK THAT- SERVE OUT
FOR THE- PREVIOUS BILL THAT WE
DISCUSSED I GUESS MY AGE. SO I
THINK WE NEED TO SEPARATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE ISSUE FROM
THOSE MANDATORY C. CONTINUE
EDUCATION IS THE PROPRIO TO
DRESSING A KNOWLEDGE
DEFICIENCY. RIGHT AT LEAST END
UP PORTION OR PERHAPS A LARGE
PORTION OF MEMBERS OF OUR
PROFESSION. AND I GUESS MY YOU
KNOW- MIKE. IS THAT FIRST OF
ALL WE DO KNOW FROM AN
EDUCATIONAL STANDPOINT
MANDATORY C. E. KNOWS THERE'S
NOTHING TO STOP THEM FROM
TAKING COURSES- OTHER THAN
POTENTIALLY THE AVAILABILITY OF
THOSE COURSES SO I THINK THE
QUESTION ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY
COURSES RAISING THE POLICY
COMMENT ACTUALLY IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE- IF THE COURSES ARE
AVAILABLE MAYBE THAT'S THE MAIN
BARRIER THAN THE REQUIREMENT
PEOPLE TAKE A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
CREDITS. IN THAT CERTAINLY
THERE'S THE MAN FOR THAT
KNOWLEDGE- PEOPLE WILL- THE
OTHER THING THAT I LOVE TO KEEP
IN MIND IS THAT- YOU KNOW THIS
ALSO IS NOT ONLY REQUIREMENT
FOR ONE TIME IT'S AN ONGOING
REQUIREMENT AND CERTAINLY WELL
THIS IS I AGREE IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC I THINK PEOPLE
SHOULD KNOW SOMETHING ABOUT IT-
IT'S- THIRTY SIX A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL BECAUSE YOU COULD HAVE
AN ARCHITECT- SHE IS VERY
KNOWLEDGEABLE IN THOSE LOTS OF
ZERO CARBON DESIGN WHO NOW
STILL HAS TO TAKE FIVE CREDITS
IN THIS WORSE THERE MIGHT BE.
SOME OTHER AREA THAT THEY- MAY
HAVE MORE OF THE- A- SO- SO
THAT'S THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE
ABOUT I THINK. MANDATORY C. E.
IT'S NOT THAT I THINK ZERO
CARBON THAT CARBON CREDIT-
DESIGN ISN'T VERY IMPORTANT IN
FACT WE SHOULD TRY TO DO IT I
AM. YEAH I DO APPRECIATE THAT
THE AMERICAN INSTITUTE OF
ARCHITECTS IS THE SPONSOR OF
THE BILL SO. THAT'S THE
PROFESSION ITSELF. ARE SAYING
THAT WE HAVE A NEED HERE WE
FEEL IMMEDIATE NEEDS SO I DO
APPRECIATE THAT- I THINK THAT-
I DO HOPE THAT WE CAN AGAIN
LOOK AT. CERTAIN OUTCOMES NOT
JUST PROCESS MEASURES WHICH IS
THE PEOPLE TAKE A CLASS I DO
THINK WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF THE VEIL BELIEVE
CLASSES. ARE ARE THESE COURSES
BECAUSE THAT MAY BE MORE OF THE
BERRIER DANNY REQUIREMENTS- AND
I CERTAINLY HEARD THE TESTIMONY
FROM THE SPONSORS ABOUT TRYING
TO DRESS THAT. SO I GUESS WITH
THAT- I DO APPRECIATE THE WHAT
THIS BILLS TRYING TO ACHIEVE
AND TO LOOK FORWARD TO. FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE CAN
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S LEADERSHIP AND
TRYING TO TRUST THIS. AND ALSO
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ARCHITECTS AS WELL AS ABOUT HOW
WE CAN TRY TO GET TO WHERE THE-
I THINK EVERYONE'S TRYING TO
GET TO- BUT I THINK AT THIS
POINT YEAH I AGAIN I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT. ACHIEVING THIS
THROUGH A MANDATORY CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENT. THAT
WE'RE LEGISLATING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DR GRAHAM. THE YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- I APPRECIATE ALL
THE COMMENTS- IN A CONCERNS
THAT OUR BY THIS WILL
DEFINITELY YOU KNOW MORE CALM
ABOUT THIS ISSUE RESPECTFULLY
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU SIR THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
NEWMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST TO MEN AND
REFERRED THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM EIGHT AB ONE
ZERO ONE ZERO DEEP PASSES
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMENDED WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ROSS HI ROSS HI
MELINDA'S ARCHULETA HI
ARCHULETA I'D BEATS BECKER HI
BACKER I DON I THOUGHT AIKMAN
HI. ADNAN I HER TADO HIGH- TATO
I JONES. JONES NO LLEVA. LEAVE
A I MADE. I MEAN I NEWMAN HI
NEWMAN I CHOSE I A SHOW ABOUT
I. LOTUS TEN EYES ONE NO WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THE CENTERS THANK YOU
SIR. LET'S GO BACK IN AND-
WE'RE GOING TO OPEN THE ROLE
STARTING WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THAT CONSENT CALENDAR
CURRENT VOTE TEN TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. B. DAUGHTER. DOT I.
HER TADO. HER TADO HI. PROVIDES
NO NOS CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT.
LET'S TAKE UP ITEM THREE BABY
FORCE WERE DUE FOR ITEM FOR
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVEN TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRUELLY. EIGHTY
FOUR SEVENTY TWO CURRENT VOTE
ELEVEN TWO ZERO MELINDA'S. B.
DAUGHTER HI DAUGHTER I. WHAT IS
TWELVE ZERO MEASURE IS OUT ITEM
NUMBER THREE ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
SIX FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
NAZARIAN. EIGHTY FOUR SIX FIVE
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TO ONE
MELINDA'S. BAIT LAVER HI LEAVE
A I'D MAN. MAN I CAN. WHAT IS
TEN TO ONE MEASURE IS OUT. I
DON'T. THE NEXT ITEM ITEM
NUMBER SIX I STILL REMEMBER
GRAYSON ASSEMBLY BILL. FIVE SIX
NINE. EIGHTY FIVE SIX NINE
CURRENT VOTE TEN TWO ZERO
MELINDA'S. BAIT LLEVA LEAVE A I
MEAN. MAN I. VOTE TWELVE ZERO
THE MEASURE IS OUT. FINALIZED
IN ITEM NUMBER EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN TEN. MAYBE TEN TIMES
CURRENT VOTE TEN TO ONE
MELINDA'S. B. EIGHT. CAN. TEN
ONE MEASURES OUT. THANK YOU TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY. IN THE OFFICIAL
RECORDS OF THIS HEARING THANK
YOU AGAIN WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION. THIS CONCLUDES OUR
AGENDA TODAY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IS ADJOURNED.